WE GOT A TRIO OF TIGHT-THICKS
AT 11:00.
- OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD, ADAM.
- OKAY, THEY'RE WAVING US OVER.
I'M GONNA GET IN THERE,
PICK-UP ARTIST STYLE, AND
START DROPPING SOME HEAVY NEGS.
- GREAT IDEA, GREAT IDEA.
- OKAY, YEAH, YEAH.
ADAM, ADAM, WHY ARE YOU--
WHY ARE YOU WALKING LIKE THAT?
- 'CAUSE I'M WALKING LIKE
I HAVE A GIGANTIC ONE,
AND YOU GUYS SHOULD, TOO.
HEY.
- HEY, WHAT'S UP, PIGS?
- UM, HI.
WILL YOU GUYS GET US SOME BEER?
- WHY, ARE YOU TOO STUPID
TO BUY IT YOURSELVES?
- OH!
OH-HO-HO-HO!
YOU GUYS LOOK DUMB.
- NO, WE'RE 19.
- OKAY, THAT'S UNDERAGE, OKAY.
- WHAT?
- I'VE GOT A BIG DICK.
IT'S HUGE.
[roars] DOWN THERE.
IT'S SCARY.
THAT'S WHY I WAS WALKING
FUNNY EARLIER,
IT'S BECAUSE IT HURTS
TO WALK.
MY THIGHS JUST SMASH IT,
AND IT'S VERY PAINFUL.
- YUP.
- OKAY, UM--
[chuckles]
THERE'S A HUGE PARTY AT
OUR DORM.
- YEAH, I KNOW.
I HEARD ABOUT THAT.
- YEAH?
- I DID.
- YEAH.
- SURPRISED US, RIGHT?
- AH, WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BRING
ALL THE BEER,
SO IF WE GIVE YOU SOME MONEY,
WILL YOU BUY IT FOR US?
- OH, LITTLE LADIES,
THAT WOULD BE OUR PLEASURE.
AND TRUST ME,
I'M BIG ON PLEASURE.
PROBABLY TOO BIG
FOR YOUR LITTLE [bleep].
[laughter]
[bleep] MIDGETS.
- DERS, HOW ABOUT YOU GIVE
THIS DUMP TRUCK OF A GIRL
HER MONEY BACK.
- OKAY. SORRY.
- UH, I DON'T GET IT.
- YOU WOULDN'T,
NOT WITH YOUR TINY BRAIN.
WHY BUY ALL THE BEER,
WHEN WE CAN STEAL ALL THE BEER?
[all gasping]
- THAT WOULD BE EPIC.
- IT WOULD BE, RIGHT?
- THAT'S WHY HE SAID IT, STUPID.
OKAY, WE'VE GOT TO TALK.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
- SEE YOU GUYS IN A FEW.
- MAYBE EASE UP A LITTLE BIT.